[Music]
well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look at what is on
the front pages time then to see what's
making the headlines with journalist and
author rachel shelby and home affairs
editor at the times matt dathan they'll
be with us from now until just before
midnight welcome to both of you so to
the front pages let us take a look shall
we starting with the metro leave means
leave the metro echoes the words of
theresa may on brexit as demands grow
for boris johnson to go now rather than
wait for a successor to be elected
but as the mirror puts it mr johnson is
determined to cling on for one last
party
the telegraph leads with the fears of
some senior conservatives that not
leaving downey street immediately leaves
the country in a state of paralysis
johnson quits defiant to the end is how
the financial times describes the prime
minister's resignation speech in downing
street
downfall that is the front of the eye
which says at least 11 tories are now
considering standing for the party
leadership
this is the times johnson throws in the
towel quoting his words when the herd
moves it moves
the guardian keeps it simple a dejected
looking mr johnson with the headline
it's
over the mail however carries an article
asking what the hell have they done with
tory mps being warned they may rue the
day they forced mr johnson out
the express is in mournful tone 2 thank
you boris you gave britain back its
freedom
while the sun shows mr johnson hugging
his family after quitting with the
headline kiss goodbye
and finally the star spoofs mr johnson's
legacy in a diary highlighting his
parties new wallpaper and his dog dylan
as his legacy in full
well don't forget by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen doing the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch the programme so let's return to
our guest then we're joined by rachel
shelby and matt dathan uh matt what a
day i'm an extraordinary new set of
newspapers you know it'll all go down in
history you never see half the payroll
of government resigning to force a prime
minister to quit and where are we at now
it's almost over is the headline in the
guardian yes that's right and you've got
so many different strands of story
haven't you you've got the telegraph is
telling us that there's real concerns in
the hierarchy of the conservative party
urging him to go sooner rather than wait
on until october with a long drawn-out
battle will you know whether all the
divisions of the party are going to be
aired throughout the summer which is
usually a very quiet time and then
you've obviously got
the mirror and the guardian almost in
celebratory mood and the male in
mournful mood so it's a real array of
stories and it's it's one of those
historic days where we'll all go and buy
the paper tomorrow i hope yes the eye
downfall that is what it is uh we were
talking with our political editor beth
rigby about how this man has always been
in the wings waiting for this job you
know he had it all he had an 80-seat
majority he could have gone on and on
and yet mistake after mistake led to a
headline like that rachel
well yes because it turns out that the
emperor has no clothes and so the
question is what made us all think that
he had these fantastic golden robes for
the last three years what was it that
gave him his donkey majority and so i'm
less concerned by the man himself i'm
more concerned by the people who enabled
his rise knowing full well exactly the
measure of the man knowing full well
that he was entirely unsuited to be the
prime minister of this country knowing
full well the kind of havoc that he
would unleash on this country before it
came to a spectacular collapse as it
inevitably would and so fine we've got
rid of this clown clown prime minister
but we haven't got rid of any of the
political or media system that enabled
it and so what's to stop this happening
if that's necessarily my question i i
know you want to have a general election
and a labor government but that wasn't
today is a sort of let's focus on boris
j
focusing on boris i'm focusing on boris
right now well i'm telling you that the
emperor has no clothes that we knew it
from the start we knew all his failings
from the start okay and so why did why
was he enabled to reach such heights in
the first place well let's look at the
metro i'm going to jump ahead uh leave
means leave he's quoting uh theresa may
and it was in fact brexit that delivered
him here the failure of teresa theresa
may but also the casting asunder of the
way that politics was normally run this
was a man who got the red wall he got
the shires that is not normal in british
politics and that's why he's here it's
not normal in tory politics either in
the places he won and i think that's
going to be that's the struggle for the
the person who's going to replace him uh
to win back there well to to to keep
those seats and i think i mean
the tory party really going to think
that they're going to win an 80-c
majority having gone through what we've
gone through and with cost of living
crisis i i it's going to be so tough and
i don't know why people want to be prime
minister tonight but but as as we're
seeing on the front of the metro i think
theresa may could have written that is
almost mocking uh boris johnson um from
the predecessor from his predecessor
and well let's stay with that theme
shall we and go to the to the mirror
we'll return to some of the other papers
that you've mentioned already um the the
daily mirror suggesting he's there for
one more party the idea they say that
he's actually got a wedding party he had
a very small wedding during parts of the
kobe pandemic of just 30 people and he's
got a big do planned at checkers and
that's why he's standing on denied i
have to say by the people in the
building behind us rachel
well yes so that's exactly what the
mirror is reporting and it
we don't know if it's true or not but we
can certainly say that it's in keeping
or in character with a man who really
has you know milked
milk to the position of prime minister
for all it's worth financially we heard
all sorts of rumors about you know
extravagantly priced wallpaper and then
there was 150 000 pound tree house that
he was going to build in checkers
um for his child before um
more sober advisors said that maybe not
such a good idea so the man obviously
has extravagant taste but this you know
coming hot on the heels of partygate
um
is going to stick in the throat for many
years
a lot of people will be trying to have
weddings again do you know what i mean
it's it's not it's not a bad thing to
want to celebrate your wedding because
at the taxpayer's expense though will
they
it's very fitting in isn't it too uh
if it gets there though i'm sure we'll
come on to whether you'll actually get
to the 30th of july indeed so well let's
go back to the the telegraph shall we
and those conservative papers who have
either chosen to or not support him
let's take a look at the the telegraph
if we can um and you know what they say
now is kind of almost critical to what
happens next isn't it the pm's longer
buy leaves the uk in a state of
paralysis and that has left disquiet it
has to be said amongst a number of
conservative mps matt hasn't it
absolutely and what's really fascinating
on the front of the daily telegraph
tomorrow is um they're reporting that
michael gove is one of those uh mps who
is
trying to urge boris johnson to step
down as soon as monday i don't think
boris johnson is going to be taking any
calls from michael gove having sacked
him this time last night but it is
interesting that someone has seen you as
michael gove who could be a king maker
let's remember in the next contest is
urging him to go and that's back on the
back of john may sir john major earlier
called on graham brady to change the
rules to uh because it's going to be
unsustainable to have boris johnson come
to number 10 for the next two months it
just seems a little bit um unsustainable
that michael gove the restaurants would
be taking michael gove's phone calls to
be fair absolutely
yeah yesterday um but you know so the
but the problem is isn't it the british
constitution does not allow for an
interim prime minister unless as andrew
bridges suggested he says he's too ill
to do it that was his suggestion and he
steps aside you know like that
yeah i mean i'm not an expert on the
constitution but what i do know is that
the conservatives have not exactly been
faithful adherents of constitutional law
or ministerial codes in the last few
years i would just say that but actually
i'm not one to uh very often praise the
telegraph but they do have quite a
substantive
front page today they make the point
that
there are so many things looming in the
next few months sure parliament will be
in recess in a few weeks but we have
this
horrible cost of living crisis coming
down the tracks martin lewis the
financial expert was speaking uh to
newsnight last night and he said we're
looking at potentially 10 million people
being plunged into poverty over the next
few months and certainly by
the colder months on top of that we've
got um strikes strike action rolling out
over the next weeks and months
chaos at the airports as the telegraph
points out
the country cannot afford for the tories
to have this yet another leadership
election while all this is going on and
so that does raise the question of who
actually is in charge who is going to
address all these very urgent issues
yeah i mean we're in a situation almost
where the civil servants are running the
country or we're not at one point today
there was nobody in education now the
teachers are threatening a pace track
who makes the decisions on
on their salaries for example so we're
in this really strange period now and i
read that the only power the 1922
committee has you have a new election
obviously uh early next week is to
expedite this process as swiftly as
possible yeah i think they do actually
have quite a lot of power because they
can not only expedite or change the
rules but they can also
um
you know decide to hold two ballots on
on a day because you've only actually
got nine days from next tuesday i think
until the following thursday when
parliament
is up so they've got to do it in nine
days so i think i think then they put
two people forward and i think they can
also expediate the process for the
members deciding um but i think this
idea that
some are making that uh let's just do
what we did in 2016 when it was a
combination of theresa may i think that
the members would be very angry with
that and not being given a choice and i
think that would cause a longer term
revolt in the conservative party than
actually having a quicker contest over
the summer yes well that's going off
just then you know it's been a long day
for them as well hasn't it for many
people here so the runners and riders
let's talk about that tonight shall we
tom tuckenhack in the telegraph writing
in the paper he said he's uh he's led
before he wants to do it again he's got
the backing possibly of some of the
moderate wing of the party uh the damian
greens of this world steve baker you
know in the in the brexit camp also
putting his name in but the problem is i
suppose for the conservatives they need
to decide who they want to be
do they how do they win the election do
they work backwards from that point and
who might do that for them rachel it's a
good question and i think the trouble is
now is that we're looking a party that
has
refashioned itself in boris johnson's
image so it has beard so far to the
right it's become a party of you know
hard right brexiteers um boris johnson
appointed and allowed to rise
people who were loyal over and above
anything else regardless of any other
talent or lack thereof and so
the candidates to begin with um you know
the people who are throwing their hat in
the ring aren't exactly
you know
blessed with the most incredible
leadership talents because that's not
why boris johnson promoted them and
meanwhile the membership in itself um
it's pretty pretty right wing i think
over 50 believe that islam is a threat
to a british way of life over 50 through
trump made a good u.s president so they
are pretty far out to the right as well
and both those things seem to suggest
that that is the sort of leader that the
conservatives are going to end up with
the financial times playing it like some
of the others johnson quits defiant to
the end picture room here obviously um
you know earlier today just before
lunchtime and then let's take a look at
the the uh the daily star uh boris
johnson's legacy in full
got a cute dog
good party organizer and nice wallpaper
um
the legacy of boris johnson matt your
view that's quite brutal and i think i
think you could be quite you could be a
little bit fairer and say that he has
led
europe i think on the war in ukraine i
think he's won a lot of plaudits and
you've seen that from blizzard um
president zielinski today even and i
think the vaccine rollout
will go down as a legacy for him as well
and uh
the conservative party think that he did
very well in making the decision just
before christmas in the new year not to
go into a lockdown when other european
countries
were so i think he did i mean i think
they could add some positives uh some
achievements to that but uh yeah there's
a long list of on the other side isn't
there 20 seconds rachel apologies for
for the shortness there is a long list
on the other side and you know the the
families of those bereaved from kovan 19
over the last few years will have a lot
to say about this about how much pain
and misery he has caused them tens of
thousands of lives needlessly
lost according to parliament's own
investigations
that will be his legacy along with
authoritarian laws including including
anti-protest laws and electoral laws
sending vulnerable people to rwanda
those things will be his legacy
that you you may have carried on for a
bit longer rachel matt thank you both
very much cindy thank you